we didn't have like normal school plays
like this is a theatrical interpretation
of an iranian poem about
birds flying to meet god
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast i
am your host your roast coming queen a
girl who
didn't read catcher in the rye until
college actually
elise morales and with us today
they're an actor they're a comedian
they're a writer you've seen them on
love life and read about them in the new
york times but before
all of that they were a graduate of the
urban school of san francisco it's just
tom hi hi elise hi
um so the urban school of san francisco
you have to tell me everything about
what that is about
okay this is crazy um let's just get
right into it
um i'm like how do i even start
well it's crazy that it's called the
urban school of san francisco quote
unquote because
it is a private high school that at the
time i attended it cost 30
000 a year to go to wow okay very fancy
very fancy um not particularly urban
um and um
of it's sort of like of like the san
francisco private high school circuit
urban was sort of like the weird one
it was like the alternative like hippie
one okay i was getting like
the name gave me a new school vibe
like was it sort of yeah it was sort of
new school
it was like all we called all the
teachers by their first names
like we didn't get grades we got written
evaluations
we like would like have a check-in every
friday where we like talked about our
feelings that was what it was like
yeah okay that's extremely different
from what my high school was like
so did you did you
thrive in this environment or were you
like i hate this
i feel like it's kind of a complicated
question because it's like
i so i had gone to public school before
that and
um going to urban was my first like 4a
into private school so i feel like i
struggled socially
very much but at the same time i
i was actually just like talking to
somebody about this and they were like
you know you have this sort of sob
story about like oh like i was in high
school i was queer
i was alone i was so lonely but like i
was also like student body president
you can be it's lonely at the top though
it is it is
it is it's like the head that wears the
crown it is
it is everybody else is all the way down
there it's hard yeah
and you're all the way up here and
you're responsible for all their little
lives
they'll never know they'll never
understand was student body president
a big deal job like did you have a lot
of responsibilities as a result of that
well so one thing about my school too
was that it was
very sort of faux politically correct in
this extremely san francisco way so like
we didn't just have one student body
president we had like a boy president
and a girl president
the girl president um
and we honestly we gave the school
announcements
in the gym every monday that's probably
how i like yeah
we've actually discussed uh being the
person who gives the announcements as
like a source of power
taylor garen also gave the announcement
yes yes
so next time if you ever see her again
you can say
i also gave the announcements i will
did you get along with your co-president
i did
he was okay so his name was david he was
this extremely tall
handsome like varsity soccer playing
all-american white boy
um so we always
everybody used to say that they thought
that i was the real president and david
was my bodyguard
and i was like that's exactly how it
should be that is exactly what i want
actually something kind of devious about
me at that time um yes here's me and
david body
um so this is me giving the
announcements at
all school meeting literally like
sitting on this white man
he's silent i have the microphone he
doesn't talk i talk
okay so now i'm understanding why the
other students got the impression
that this man worked for you
we did um one year for or this year um
senior year for halloween um
i was lois lane and he was uh
clark kent as superman and we did this
bit where
i like a boy dressed as a ninja came out
to attack me and he like ripped his
shirt open and picked me up and carried
me away
oh okay did the student body like
ship you guys do you think
like romantically yeah no i mean i was
off the table
so i wasn't sure if you i was like were
you out at this time what was the
situation because i was like maybe
they were shipping you i was so i was
um yeah my high school experience was
very colored by me
having been out as like some kind of
gay or queer or lesbian um all through
high school
so as early as like freshman year the
first day
i i decided because i knew i was a very
early
sort of bloomer in that specific way
very very late in many other ways
yeah um but i i already knew when i was
like in eighth grade that i was gay but
i was like i'm not gonna
like talk about it here and then when i
went to high school i was like well i'm
i have this fresh new start
i specifically picked this weirdo school
where i was like i think it's going to
be okay for me to do this here and i
just decided i didn't want to do that
thing where
i like came in and then came out and
changed people's perception of me
so i just was like i'm just going to be
like gay in high school
so it was just that that makes so much
more sense that it like
to just start out gay from day one
is a lot easier than having to like go
through that process of coming out and
having like a
day where you're telling people and
they're telling people and all of that
stuff it was just
i just didn't want to deal with it i
just was like let me just
be this thing and then people can decide
if they like that or not i don't want to
like everybody's feelings i do love
being like listen
i'm a queer teenager i have enough on my
plate and i don't need to be dealing
with all of this other nonsense
i was lucky i was very lucky and i mean
that comes from like being in san
francisco
and like yes being in these little
levels
was your school like accepting in the
way that you
expected was there a queer community at
your high school
so there was um there was and like i had
a lot of gay friends
um actually i my whole little group
of people um was queer teenagers our
overlap was
we were we did um
[Music]
theater fencing and poetry club
and at the intersection of those three
clubs
where all of my friends that's a
beautiful
gay venn diagram that's just
it's really it ah that's great did you
so did you do those three activities or
were you
like drama club where did you let it was
deep
in all three of those i was
yes i did high school theater i was
captain of the fencing team my senior
year
um and actually i was poetry club
president which i forget a lot of the
time
um oh my god so okay fencing
the only things i know about fencing are
from uh
parent trap so yeah i was going to ask
how did you get into fencing how did
fencing come into
your life well we didn't have
traditional pe
classically um so the way that pe worked
at my school was that
we had sort of like extracurricular
classes that happened
outside of school that you could sign up
for um
and so i i did i did fencing i don't
know i like swords
i've already sort of been like this i
mean if if i had had the option to take
fencing i
absolutely would have took fencing
instead i was very bad at it
pe at my school like i remember there
was a month where they would just have
us walk around the field
every day and then and we called it
going for a walk
i would have loved that did you gossip
oh we gossiped
so much and i think honestly the
practice of
taking us for a walk had to end because
drama was starting and people would
uh like people would leave the walk and
like like sneak away from the trail
and make out with each other and like oh
my god
it became there was it became too
dangerous to take us for a walk every
day so we lost no you had too much
freedom
we were too free
i did i snuck off one time and went
behind this shed
instead of going on my walk and i didn't
even really do anything
and then the teacher caught me and he
called me a smart ass
well i mean vandalized yeah no he
he shouldn't have called you that but
you probably were one oh i absolutely
was and he was 100
right and but i was completely
scandalized i was like
he dares curse upon me
he perceives me accurately
he's telling me the truth about my
actions
so what was your relationship to like
your schoolwork
and your teachers at that point because
if you weren't
i imagine like if you're calling them by
their first
names and all that stuff were they like
buddies
or they kind of they kind of were
and it's funny to me now that i
am the age that i am which i'm not going
to name on the recording
but now now i'm like oh those were like
regular people teaching at a private
school because it was private school so
you don't have to like jump through as
many hoops as
it would be to teach a public school
which is so interesting like you would
it's wrong
it's wrong i mean i'm glad that our
public school teachers are as highly
trained as they are but it's just odd to
me
i agree no you can truly be any old
person
i think um to whatever specific
standards of the school but like we had
you know we had a science teacher who
was probably like 27
um and like super hot and like everybody
would think that she was like a hot
senior girl when they came
in um but she was the teacher and she
would like
look at law cats in the middle of class
that was the other thing about my school
is that we all had it was a tech forward
school so we all had laptops we all had
like smart boards and [ __ ]
we were doing like very technologically
advanced things
i remember the advent of the smart board
like when they kind of swept into my
school and
like half the teachers would have them
and half the teachers would
not have them and a quarter of the
teachers who had them knew how they
worked
so exactly it would always get
disattached from the pen
or whatever and then they would have to
like reconfigure it
it was really too bad we were like you
could just write on the chalkboard
that's behind the smart board
but we probably like we probably
were the sort of like tester type school
where we
were using all that technology probably
a little bit before
yeah to see if it worked did you learn
like
code at school i didn't so i didn't come
away with almost anything
useful like in a money-making sort of
way i learned to get in touch with my
feelings
um i learned you know i read
like chekov and i read like the classics
and i read like shakespeare but i didn't
actually learn
any real technological anything i
learned how to like covertly
send a text to my friends without anyone
noticing like that's what i learned how
to do
yeah it but i mean honestly
teaching teenagers how to get in touch
with their feelings is a very valuable
thing to do like i do feel that more
schools should be doing that
i agree yeah i agree i mean it was a
whole sort of weird thing because
we really liked to talk a lot of talk at
my school
and i don't think it like really
structurally fit exactly what was going
on
like um like we had um we had a speaker
come in one time
this person named renata who was
literally a
black genderqueer like gender
non-conforming trans person
who just came in to speak to us like
about their experience
of their life in like 2006 or something
like a really long time ago
um before people were talking about
stuff like this so on one hand that was
happening
on the other hand like the boys were all
calling themselves
calling each other [ __ ] on facebook and
stuff so it was like
yeah man people were
really doing that then like when
we were growing up really a lot and
it's like sometimes i think back on it
and i'm like
i knew kids back in the day who wouldn't
swear but would still say that
like it lit like crazy crazy stuff
well it's a word it's a term it's a
title
yeah no it's it's funny to say because
it whatever anyway
we don't need to get into that but
so okay as you are at the school and
you're seeing
you know like a black trans person is
coming to speak to you and all that
stuff
how are you experiencing that with your
own queerness like or you're on your own
like
gender identity so i was sort of
deep in uh
early 2000s neoliberalism whole at that
time
so i didn't even i remember watching
renata and being like this is very cool
and like later they came and like spoke
specifically at gsa where i also was
and i was like this is cool but like i
didn't
ever think to like apply it to myself
and then so now as an adult i'm like if
i didn't get that
then like what were any of these kids
getting out of that
if i didn't get it yeah it's so funny
for
you as a young kid to be
standing to be standing so close
to you're like so close yet so far away
is the image that i'm getting exactly
because you just weren't i guess you
know you just weren't ready
for that information yet i wasn't ready
i kind of
really thought that i had myself all
figured out because
i had sort of figured out this one thing
about myself very early on
i kind of was like and that's good
enough i can we're done and we've closed
the book on that yes
we have no more growth to do we have
grown to the greatest extent we know
everything about ourselves and we need
not ask anymore
and that's that
it took me years it took me some
years later to be like ah yes like
actually there's more
oh it seems that there's another volume
to this book
i am still going we are still alive
so were you dating at this time
who are you so i'm only
just now as an adult realizing what a
weird experience it was to be queer at
this school at this time
because like i said i did have lots of
queer friends
but we did not date each other at all we
were
it was very almost like ick like almost
like
that's so interesting because in my
little straight friend group we were
dating each other obsessively
creating horrible toxic scenarios
amongst ourselves
i wonder what that was about with us
that we just weren't
into doing that with each other and then
something interesting is
so i always had these like intense
unrequited like suffering crushes
on these other girls outside my friend
group some of whom
were sort of like ambiguously something
because it was san francisco
you could be whatever and then some of
whom
were like straight like actually this is
kind of a sore subject for me right now
because
i just found out that um this person who
i actually i went to junior prom with um
and i confessed to them at some point
that i had a crush on them and they sort
of were like i don't swing that way but
like you're really cool whatever
sorry um i just found out like a couple
weeks ago that now
they're a non-binary trans person
and i'm like that's great you know
that's great i'm so happy
for you but i'm like why did i have to
feel weird
yeah but you also hurt my feelings
it's all weird 15 years ago but that's
you
watching that like watching that one
of that person speak and being like
not ready to accept the information
you're right
[Music]
that's a great perspective actually
that's actually a really really smart
read on this situation
yeah i've been recording a lot of
episodes of the podcast lately so
that's very insightful elise thank you
for that i'm gonna
consider that on my own time later i'm
gonna try to let go of just the pure
bitterness that i feel about this
and try to like have empathy for the
people around me
everybody's learning no but i would be
extremely pissed off too i mean
i have attachments to people from high
school that it's
like it's it's wrong like i'm sick
for still looking at their page every so
often i come around again to see where
everybody's at and it's interesting
because
almost everybody who was like a girl
in high school is some total
other type of thing now in like lots of
different ways like
sometimes it's that they were super
queer and weird in high school and now
they're really normal
um the guys are exactly the same but
just worse
they have not progressed but in a
in a different way no and like i had one
friend
who was a trans girl in high school
um and as far as i know none of the
people who i knew to be
boys quote unquote in high school have
like transitioned or like changed their
gender in any sort of way like none of
them
other than like my one friend that's so
interesting i wonder like
so were you able to like decide to go to
this school like did you choose it
i did so what happened was um i was an
extremely precocious
and advanced teenager no
i can't say very annoying very know it
all
um and so at my public middle school
um the teachers were sort of like okay
chess is sort of like really a big fish
in a small pond here and like
maybe you my mom should think about
like looking at private schools um and i
actually
i actually had really really wanted to
go to like the very prestigious very con
conservative um private school
what i don't know what was that one
called do you remember
it was called these names are so stupid
it was called university
university high school the big three
okay just wait
the big three sorry i was just gonna say
i love
fancy people's high school names because
it's it's absurd
they're insane the big three private
high schools in san francisco
are the urban school university high
school and
lick wilmerting
no yeah slick wilmerding
what what is lik
what is what is like wilmerding's like
reputation
i'm sorry that's really [ __ ] up and i
actually feel really bad for the kids
you feel bad for um for mr lick and mr
wilmerding who got together to start
this school
oh you know what i'm sorry but if you
and your buddy want to start a school
and your names
are lick and wilmerding you're like we
can't name it after ourselves like
be a little bit creative someone has a
grandma
someone has a different name right take
a let's take a step back and look at
yourselves you can't name a school for
children lick wilmerding
okay what was of the three if like the
urban school is the
weirdo one and the university's the
conservative one what is
like wilmington hufflepuff it's just
like it is hufflepuff actually
it was i think their colors were
actually yellow and black um
it is i think that it's kind of the
sleeper of the three like i think it's
the real
weirdo school at lick you major
in an art like you can major in like
metal work or like jewelry making
or something like that i actually kind
of wish i had done that instead
well yeah and then i mean for just
comedic purposes you could be like my
high school was like
i would never get past just that fact
just that bass fact
yeah you would get you would get on
stage you would say that you would get a
15-minute standing ovation
and i would just i drop the mic i walk
off
and then and every article will be like
this year is just topsy
it's like just tom lick wilmerding like
that's my credit
exactly they attended lick wilmerding
high school
i mean that is truly how i bring
everyone in on this podcast but
it's yes am i imagine
i'm glad that we got here when we did so
okay
let's talk about your theater career
because that's just an important part of
every episode
absolutely absolutely it is
uh what plays did you do what were
what what were the big uh the big just
tom
performances so typical of
my weird alternative school we didn't
have
like normal school plays so like i have
almost no clout
with like high school theater kids
because we didn't do
like grease or like i don't know miss
saigon
or whatever like place that people heard
of we were doing like
this is like this is a theatrical
interpretation of an iranian poem about
birds flying to meet god across the
country like
i think we have some photos that we put
together of your theater program that
illustrate this super well
so um for for our audio listeners
it appears there's a spotlight on a body
on the ground
and yes and jess is standing next to it
giving a news report
yes um so this is uh this is if virginia
2.0
by charles me it is a
modern day adaptation of virginia at
alice which we
set during the iraq war classically as
every play
from like 2004 to 2008 was set in the
iraq war
okay okay something that i as a teenager
really
understood and um i should be speaking
on
um yes you should absolutely be making a
statement yeah
i agree no i i i do agree on that
um but i am playing
um so the thing about the thing about
charles mee's plays is that he straight
up is like
look adapt this play change it
fix it move it around mix it up so we
actually added
three characters um to this play
um we added the the fates um from greek
mythology and i
am a tropos the like the string cutting
fate
yeah so at this point in the play if
shania has
sacrificed herself and i am making
uh some sort of speech about it that i
had
written myself
um the girl on the ground here
is um clytemnestra if janae's mom um
the sort of the like hot mommy of greek
mythology i also had a massive crush on
this exact girl who was playing this
role
so i just love
having a play that's written by a famous
playwright that also just has like a
couple speeches written by like high
schools
yeah on the iraq war about the iraq
the metaphor of the iraq war so
um was this this was an unrequited crush
on this girl or requited
it was unrequited i actually in this
exact play had a
total like mental breakdown after
casting
because i we gender swapped a few of the
roles
and i desperately wanted to play
achilles who gets like a dance scene
with her
and at the time i really really thought
i just really wanted to play that role
and now as an adult i'm like no i was in
love with that
girl number one and number two i wanted
to play a young man
that's what like
there are clues it's interesting to find
the clues along the way
[Music]
but who among us hasn't had a breakdown
after casting
that's what casting is for just to like
ruin
the mental health of like 10 to 20
teenagers
absolutely i mean i remember not getting
a part i wanted and you can't take it
with you
and being furious at the end did you
deserve that
i listen i was one of the strongest
people in the program
and uh i think that
there you know what a choice was made
and you're right some people
do you know it's their senior year i
guess or whatever
some people just can't see what's
obviously in front of them
yeah i mean listen there's politics
there's obviously politics that goes
into these things
and um someone got the first one so
this is a later uh casting injustice
this was senior year college
but i was in a horrible production of a
midsummer night's dream
um the second horrible production of a
midsummer night's dream i've ever done
and um and i was
not cast as puck and i was like
are you an idiot like
[Laughter]
are you literally stupid like look at me
like
i'm the puck i am the puck here that
uh that is the most uh
that feeling especially when you're like
going out for plays
is so it's i don't even get
to that level of outrage going out for
stuff that i go out for now as i did
like seeing the cast list and feeling
overlooked for a part in like
the school fall production of course
well because a play is such a commitment
it's a lifestyle
it is a lifetime an entire lifetime
occurs
within one production of a play yes and
so
much you fall in and out of love like
guys friendships are made and broken
absolutely tensions run high
things did not get sexy for me but
things got
see i never like okay my senior year
i was i was in a love triangle in the
drama department that caused a bit of a
friction
oh but
one of one of those people is very scary
now uh in the
triangle and i really should have just
picked the other one
but we're leaving that in the past
i was more of like a big deep dark
secret crush type
like a dark like like make a whole
playlist on a cd
put it in your student mailbox and never
speak of it again
yeah yeah sometimes i i like will think
back
in nostalgia to the unrequited crushes
of my past i just like
and just marvel at my own depth of
feeling
like i don't feel anything like that
anymore
i would love a boy with my
whole body like i would just be like
and someone who i like when we're
talking early middle school and stuff
like it would be
like boys i did not talk to and i would
absolutely
just be in in love with them
in love i mean that girl on the floor
clyde nestra i don't know anything about
her
i don't know anything about her like i
mean i definitely spent a lot of time
with her doing that play but like we
weren't really like friends or anything
we don't like hang out
we did not know her
[Laughter]
but that's i feel like that's why those
crushes get that way because it's so
much a person that you like create in
your head and there's so much
you're not really bringing in any past
experiences
you're just bringing in like stuff you
know from movies and tv
absolutely absolutely and then for me
there was this whole sort of speculative
aspect
of like would this person even
ever be interested in me or ever be
interested in somebody like me
yeah um and what is funny is that
actually a lot of them
might have been but i was too like
afraid
and yeah yeah and it's it's interesting
because like
that i even as like a straight
like middle schooler and stuff it's i
my fear kept me from like admitting my
crushes on so many people it's like
of course that boy also wanted to kiss
you
he is a 13 year old boy if you offer to
kiss him he's gonna
kiss you exactly exactly but then it's
hard because it's like on the other hand
then i had that experience of literally
telling that person i had a crush on
them and them being like i am not
into you for this specific reason and
now that's not true anymore
so yeah well yes you were
you had an added date you you had an
added danger
it was just embarrassing that i love
being like
it was just invested well that whole
experience was so humiliating me and
this person had gone
we that was my friend and we did hang
out and again that person
like asked me to prom junior year and
then like
i feel like that's a little
but were they it was friends prom
supposedly
they asked me to prom and then kind of
didn't hang out with me
all night and i felt some type of way
about that
and because i sort of was like why would
you even do this if you didn't want to
even
like hang out with me um and then
years later
i hear this story come up on the roast
if
any teenagers are listening don't take
someone to prom if you don't want to
hang out with them when you get there
just take somebody else promise a
commitment
yeah if you don't is a time-honored
tradition if you take someone to prom
you gotta hang out with them
follow through follow through there are
no teenagers who listen to this podcast
and i'm always
i'm always giving them advice saying
like for the teens who listen like
they're
i do not know of any but they're like
doing drugs and kissing someone else
these people seem old and weird
[Laughter]
mom turn that off mom
um let's look through some of the photos
that you sent because these
these are really beautiful um
okay let's look this is another play
this is another play okay for those who
are listening we have
two black and white like very artsy
photos
uh jess is wearing a full suit and some
heels
um and then you've also got a friend
with you in one
in one of the photos so were these like
the promotional images for the play
they were when you go to alternative san
francisco high school
this is the sort of promotional images
that get put up for the school play no
text no nothing just um
these didn't have other text on them
when they were put up
maybe they did okay i was like wait
um this was um an adaptation
of the jack nicholson movie chinatown
um called chinatown
415 um because it took place in san
francisco
in the future and was about lesbians um
that rocks thank you thank you but like
i said it has no clout among
high school theater people um i did play
the jack nicholson role
um and um
yeah this was something that was
actually very very cool about my school
was that we didn't do um traditional
auditions like to be in a play
you were in a class and then they cast
out of the class so you were definitely
in it um and they also sort of picked
the play
based on who was in the class um and so
senior year they actually sort of were
like we're gonna put jess in the lead
role so we're gonna pick this play
that like literally for some reason in
the adaptation was a
chinese-american lesbian jack nicholson
and they were like only jess can play
this role
it really was created for you
to assume the role it was um it was i
was very lucky
to be able to do that um and then here
this also is my friend kate who played
the uh faye dunaway role
wow okay so i mean i am meant i have to
imagine that you took this very
seriously oh my god
it was so serious and so intense
um
i was
don't know like this was i got i got a
kiss in this one
whoa me and kate
in the picture we we had a little kiss
kiss
yeah it's huge i mean for real good on
your school though because
my like i mean my high school would have
never come anywhere
close oh my god my public virginia
there's no way we were crazy like
actually
in the conversation where we were
talking about
um that we were going to do a kiss
um it was our theater teacher francis
and one of my other mentors ellen
sebastian chang
who is like a bay area theater person
she's this like super weird like cool
black woman
um and she and frances were old-time
friends and she was the one who actually
adopted the play
um so they were talking to us and they
were like okay and then at this point
you're gonna
have to do a kiss um and you know people
make a big deal out of this but it's not
a big deal and
ellen goes and grabs francis the teacher
and just
makes out with her friend of all of us
you know it's like 6 p.m on a wednesday
or something after rehearsal
and you're just like um oh yeah yeah so
like [ __ ] like that was happening
all kinds of things can happen at
private school there are no rules
it's anarchy you know what that has been
my understanding of private schools so
it's good to have it
uh have that confirmed do you remember
this is a question i love
to ask do you remember any of the big
rumors scandals happenings
of your school big troubles
etc um
a huge scandal at my school uh
was when one year
somebody brought a a
christmas tree and set it up in the old
library which was where the seniors hung
out and it was it was a pretty
secular christmas tree like it was just
a tree with like a string of pink lights
on it
but people flipped out
um because it was not politically
correct
to put up a christmas tree um and we
we were the pc school yeah and we had a
lot of jewish students who were like
we don't like this i don't even know if
it was the students who started it i
actually think it was a faculty member
who started it
um and then people being like well no
like we don't want to put up um menorah
or whatever because that's like a real
religious holiday and it's like not the
same as christmas which is so
commercialized and like christmas
symbols which are so commercialized
we don't actually like we do not like
this
and we don't want
to like try to rectify it in any sort of
way and they ended up having to move the
christmas tree into like the dean's
office
[Laughter]
the dean just having a private christmas
tree
yeah and if you wanted to see the
christmas tree you had to go into the
dean's office
do you remember like where you stood on
the issue
i think i thought it wasn't a big deal
and everybody was making a really big
deal out of it and i think that's still
how i feel
i mean i get it like as an adult i'm
like yes i do understand
being really annoyed at being like
having to be around all this like
christmas [ __ ] all the time but like
it was kind of a cute gesture that
somebody did that was like nice
for the school and like it wasn't it was
a string of ping lights you know
it wasn't like super christmassy yeah i
mean
i i feel like it is the perfect thing
though for like
young liberal
kids in like early 2000s to like
recognize and rail against as well like
once the teacher brought it up it's like
i feel i feel like it teenagers have
such a like black and white
understanding of like what's supposed to
be happening so
i feel like it is a very like high
school thing to be like we're the pc
school that's not pc
get the tree out that's like
we have to be again against the tree
when it's like well let's actually think
about it
maybe the tree is just kind of nice
right
it i just thought it wasn't a big deal
but we were always fighting about stuff
like we had
whole online forums which was where all
these conversations would go down
oh [ __ ] so i guess that's part of being
the tech school
yeah yeah so we had a lot of intense
like internet arguments
i would this go on on like aim or like
legitimate like forums we had
um our own i don't know what you would
even call this but we had our own like
server thing that we were all on just
for the school
and you could start drama there
absolutely absolutely that was what it
was for
okay so it like wasn't like it's like it
wasn't monitored by like the teachers or
anything like
it was it was monitored by the teachers
and like big
big things actually would really go down
at this school like the christmas tree
example is sort of absurdist
there are a lot of other like really
intense like you know having like
a intense argument about
race yes yeah and like racism
um that like led to like real material
consequences
and like people being really hurt and
like yeah yeah people really revealing
themselves in this way the christmas
tree is like
christmas is like a fun one to talk
about on podcasts
yeah the other one is like there's a lot
to unpack actually with this other
situation
so okay you could like half
i'm so obsessed with the server now like
what type of drama
like could you call people out by name
on the server or was it more like a
private message you would send someone
to be like i've seen
i see that what you're the [ __ ] you're
up to
um it was like
it was like my my friends
you know one of my friends one time uh
performed a spoken word poem
for the feminist club at all school
meeting
and then boys would get on and be like
i felt really misunderstood by the
feminist poem
like it was like
damn so that kind of drama okay
okay it was okay
things got kind of dark sometimes like
ultimately what ended up happening
because these huge sort of dramas would
come out
of like the students of color club
having an all-school meeting or the
feminist club having an all-school
meeting
and really honestly like it's not that
they were starting drama it's that they
were being real about like their
experiences
in this environment um but then within
the time that i was at the school
they stopped allowing those clubs to
have that kind of
uh meeting wow so you you
when you were there a club like gsa
or like a students of color club could
call could run
the all school meeting or call one yeah
yeah
and they stopped allowing that they
changed it
so that it was like a club could host
like an outside speaker coming in but
the students themselves could no longer
get up
and like air grievances basically in
front of the whole school
ah wow okay that's so interesting
one do you think like was there any
merit to that decision or is it just
them being
like we don't want the kids to talk no
more i kind of think it was a [ __ ] move
okay yeah i was like that's my initial
impression but i'm like i wonder like
maybelline meetings are getting crazy
i think it was a [ __ ] move and i think
that it was people
just like ultimately honestly
it was changing the environment so that
like the white boys at school felt more
comfortable
yeah so that they couldn't be like
called to account at this like meeting
at school or whatever
right i mean yeah i i don't want to hear
a poem that made me feel bad
no we did a lot of cosmetic [ __ ] like
that like i remember
um there was one year that one of the
boys running for co-president
was like i'm the homie's choice like
that's what his poster said the homies
choice and they made him take that down
because it wasn't okay for him to like
say homies
yeah i mean it's high school is an
interesting time which i guess is the
point of this podcast um
in conclusion high school is an
interesting time
we actually do have more photos to look
at for you so that is not the conclusion
i wanted to talk about this one because
both claudia our producer and i thought
this was a very cute little film strip
so
who are we looking at here okay so
um so i did have a girlfriend yes at the
very very end
uh of senior year of high school
um yes this was my first girlfriend ever
um we
this was sort of funny too because once
we got together
um people kind of treated it like it was
a secret
when it wasn't really a secret you're
like no we
we took a bunch of photos in this photo
yeah
yeah like that's interesting so
other people just assumed that your
relationship wasn't public just because
it was queer sort of yeah and i didn't i
didn't know this at the time
but later on i learned that there was
like actually a lot of secret queer [ __ ]
happening at this school that i was not
privy to
and i was not like allowed into really
because like i was not a secret
i was very out oh that's so interesting
so
like they kind of didn't want to they
didn't let you into their like closet
club kind of sort i mean i don't i don't
know i haven't
heard this from anyone but my projection
my emotional projection
is that i was excluded from some of this
like secret queer drama
and like specifically like secret queer
girl drama yeah because
i like it just wouldn't have been a
secret with me
yeah i mean that makes sense if it's
like
if they feel like it's like well this
other person is
like like they might compromise the
secret with their very presence
i mean and i wouldn't have had it be a
secret i mean this was not a secret
me and my girlfriend at that time so how
long did you two date
we dated um we dated a year um from the
end of senior year high school
through most of first year of college
which was not a good idea we should not
have done that we should have broken up
right when high school ended maybe at
the end of the summer
um yeah having a nice little summer
together end it when it was nice
and then that's it it's a hot it's hard
not to make that mistake
these matters of the heart you know it's
complicated you think how far apart were
you
in like college
um like geographically yeah distance
yeah um i went to smith in massachusetts
and she went to nyu
okay so it's like not it's not close
but not far yeah like i would
like we would see each other a couple
times a month
um i would take the bus to new york um
and then
actually she eventually ended up
transferring
to smith after we had broken up
oh hi yeah yeah in a kind of classic
lesbian move
so what um how did you how did your
courtship
begin did was it like your pursuit
of her so we were
um classic close female friends
um and it was just this thing where like
kind of for years
we had a very close friendship
which i don't i wonder what your take on
this
is elise because in my experience a lot
of
like straight women and especially like
straight white women
have this very kind of gray relationship
with each other
yes like were they like always like
touching each other's faces and like
kissing
and being like i want to marry you i
love you
yeah and well also when when i was
growing up i felt like
girls making out with each other
platonically quote-unquote
was having a major moment in the culture
it was in the class my culture was born
in 2007
[Laughter]
that all bisexuals can be traced down to
the year 2007.
well we've talked about this actually
they can be traced to the episode of the
oc where misha barton and olympia
of course of course that is actually the
spark
when bisexual when all bisexuality
that is the big bang of bisexuality it
was
it was but i just remember there was
like a lot of
girls who were best friends who would
make out at lunch
and at our school and they were friends
but they would make out at lunch
and then these two twins did it
and no no yeah and then and then the
trend ended
the trend
you know what it went really far and we
need to pull back wow
that's a good scandal that was a good
scandal
and it wasn't i don't even remember it
being that scandalous i just remember
everyone being like
that was really weird and like we really
can't let that happen again
and we need to we need to simmer down at
lunch
collectively bringing homophobia back
you know what we opened up things got
too liberal and some crazy
too progressive this is what happens
this is what happens this is exactly
what george's bush is saying on the tv
and now we've got incestuous
relationships
full incest
uh listen all i'm saying is that's what
happened at my school
so i think we have one more photo that
we chose that's yeah oh we've got two
okay is this a school dance we that we
are looking at here
this is this is junior prom this is not
my date um
but this is uh also somebody who uh
came out as queer later on in adulthood
um yeah i just think
i just think this is such a funny
example of like
i'm like wearing doc martens at prom i'm
wearing this like
black lace vintage dress and your friend
has a very betsy johnson
like the bright pink yes yes
the sort of betsy johnson hot topic yes
both of you are serving a betsy johnson
hot topic
situation here we're on a boat also
um oh wow you had a dance on a boat
that's funny we did
we had a boat prom yeah and this is yeah
this is me hanging out with someone who
was not my dad because my dad didn't
hang out with me that much
that night which again
to the teens who aren't listening don't
do that
don't do this hang out with your date
okay the page make it so that
sorry you finished your thought make it
so that 15 years later
uh saw your date uses a picture of you
guys together on a podcast exactly
exactly don't put yourself in this
position where you're nowhere to be
found on the podcast
you want to be in this podcast trust um
okay
there is a picture of you that i love
this picture is so
cute to me because it has such uh
myspace energy
to me uh was this a user photo
it was um it was well this was one of my
first ever
facebook photos um which i got facebook
like sophomore year high school
i feel like this is just such a like
classic like
what i looked like at that time yes and
i
i was always like this was a classic way
that i would structure my photos
too where like you're not in the center
you're looking off to the side
like the only thing you're not doing is
kind of like the mouth to the side
the little like i
i took a lot of i wish i could find
these because i i
i don't know where they could be but
there are so many photos
of those like downward angle oh yeah
but i'm like inside the shower kind of
photos
i took so many yeah from that angle and
then i would also use the flash so it
would just be like kind of my eye
yes yes um and then i would
turn the saturation up super high too on
my phone
and make them make the colors really
bright
and it was a digital camera at that time
so you were just you were just shooting
you were just shooting and hoping you
had no idea what that picture looked
like
oh i would i mean i still will do this
from time to time but i would take so
many pictures on the digital camera
and like trying to get the flash right
in the mirror
and like all of that all of your mom is
like why have you been in the bathroom
for 25 minutes
yes and i'm just like just leave me
alone i'm trying to get this right now
shut up shut up
is it private just like try and explain
to my parents what myspace is
oh my god myspace was such a stressor at
that time
like i yeah is there anything more
cruel than the top 8 system as it was
devised
absolutely not absolutely not it is a
hurtful
feature that was horrible yeah
list publicly your friends in order of
helping
order in descending order
yeah and if you make a new friend sorry
one's gotta go
i i remember like the trend of like when
your friends would write like a big
paragraph
about you that you would put on myspace
um and my friends weren't into stuff
like that and so i never
i never had anything like that the uh
the like little like online like digital
markers
of friendship were so huge like i um
i've talked about this on the podcast
before but me and my friends
would if you said something really funny
on aim like
l-o-l they would copy and paste it into
their aim
profile yes yes
and as a budding comedian i was trying
to get in people's profiles man i
i was like putting in work on am trying
to make my friends laugh so i'd get in
their profile
and did you oh yeah absolutely
i used to have for years actually
because eventually facebook changed
enough that
i didn't even remember these sections
existed but there was like a quote
section on facebook
yes and mine was totally full
of stuff actually a quote from that
uh young science teacher um that i
talked about before where she was like
gila monsters can reproduce completely
without like
it was like two
female gila monsters can reproduce with
each other
so in conclusion we don't need men i'm
not sexist i'm just a scientist
and i had that quote for years oh my
face
i remember i remember like yeah facebook
used to have
you could do notes on facebook
and i remember i used to write reviews
of the
show secret life of the american
teenager
on facebook notes and people would read
them and it was like this
early comedy writing of mine because i
thought that show was very dumb
and uh all of them are gone now and
that's probably good so
that archive is gone yeah facebook
removed the notes feature and i think
that's
probably for the best all right jess i
feel like we have come
to the end here but before i let you go
i have to ask you what we ask
every guest on the podcast which is
if you could talk to team jess today
what would you tell them
if i could talk to teen jess today
with all of my wisdom i have now i would
be like
dude chill out there will come a time
when
you will sleep with many brown-haired
white girls
you'll do it so much that you're going
to be like i actually don't really want
to do that that much anymore
and then um someday everyone is going to
go
gaga over the vice president's
stepdaughter who's a brown-haired white
girl and you're gonna go actually i
don't even need to look at this person
and you're gonna feel crap
i've actually moved beyond ella
emma
i wish i could show teen jazz a picture
of ella amhoff and be like someday you
will not have a crush on this girl
yeah someday this will mean nothing to
you
you'll look at this and you will feel
[Laughter]
nothing
oh god ella is a friend of the pod you
know we would love to have you ella i
know you just booked a major contract
we know you were a teenager once we know
that ella was a teenager once all right
jess it was so great having you on the
pod
always a delight a friend of the show
from from its live show days uh and
to everyone listening at home this has
been the roast of your teenage self
podcast
[Music]
you